welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host on an
ongoing basis
today i am joined by greg he's currently
the permanent guest co-host uh for the
time being greg thank you for joining me
thanks for having me on
uh so if you like the show
and you would like to support it there
are many ways that you can do that you
can like rate or subscribe wherever you
happen to get podcasts
you could join our email newsletter you
can do that at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter that is totally free
you could use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com if you use the code
sbs pod you get five percent off your
entire order
and of course you could also
download and use macro factor the diet
app that we created
it does have a free trial so there's
no risk you can try it out see if you
like it and go from there
now
another way to support us
is by subscribing to the mass research
review and that is going to be a huge
focal point
of today's show
right now
at the time you're listening to this
episode
uh there's a big sale going on for the
mass research review it is our annual
anniversary sale and this is a special
one because it's the five year
anniversary of the mass research review
i don't consider the first couple years
to be necessarily part of the mass canon
because i wasn't involved yet so the
five-year anniversary there's kind of an
asterisk there it's like
five-ish years but really kind of three
more or less but um anyway in today's
episode we're gonna go through the best
of mass issue um which is basically we
gathered up all of our favorite articles
from the last year and we actually put
out a pdf that is freely available so if
you go to strongerbyscience.com
mass best of with a hyphen between those
three words
you can download the best of mass issue
see if you like it and if you do like it
we think you should consider subscribing
to it
and like i said during this sale these
are going to be the best prices of the
year the sale is currently ongoing and
it ends on tuesday
may 3rd so if you subscribe to mass
during the sale
the price points are 21 us dollars per
month if you do a month to month
subscription
209 us dollars per year or you can get a
lifetime membership a lifetime
subscription for 6.99
uh if you're an existing member and you
want to upgrade to a lifetime
subscription during the sale the upgrade
price is
599 us dollars um so
like i said a huge part of today's
podcast content is that we're going to
go through some of our content from the
best of mass over the last year um and
what's really nice is if you hear that
some of these conversations and you
think they're interesting you can go and
download the issue and read the the
actual articles to get even more detail
on some of the topics we're discussing
here we're going to go through about
half of the best of mass issue the other
half is supposed to be discussed on iron
culture i i believe that's what we're
doing but i have no insight into what
goes on in that side of the world that
that is what we were told was going to
happen so
if it does cool if not it's not on us
yeah theoretically the iron culture
podcast episode on may 2nd is supposed
to discuss the other half of this best
of mass issue
if it doesn't
go check out their feed
on may 2nd if they don't cover the other
half of this just absolutely drown them
in negative emails negative reviews
mean-spirited comments and
all sorts of things like that
uh all right before we get into the best
of mass uh first of all greg feats of
strength what do you have for us this
week yeah so uh christoph weir bicky
recently pulled the
as far as i'm aware third heaviest
deadlift of all time so uh number one
you have uh half thor bjornsson who
pulled
kilos friend of the show then you uh
yeah sure we met him that counts
it does i suppose uh then you have eddie
hall uh i suppose an enemy of the show
maybe haven't met him uh correct uh and
you know i don't think he and thor get
along they they tried to beat each other
up that one time uh and thor seemed cool
so sure eddie hall enemy of the show we
interrupted his dinner and he didn't
mind
that is correct yeah um
yeah he pulled 500 kilos and both of
those guys are uh are huge individuals
i'm pretty sure they both weighed
like north of 180 kilos like north of
400 pounds when they hit those numbers
uh so
number three all time just in terms of
who has locked out the heaviest weight
is now christopher picky who last time
he competed he was 104 kilos like uh 230
pounds much smaller guy
uh he pulled 490
kilos or 1080 pounds in the gym uh as
far as i could tell it was a raw
deadlift i don't think he was wearing a
suit if so he was wearing a suit that
has very short legs under his normal
clothes but i'm pretty sure it was raw
he was wearing straps but
the other two deadlifts also
had had straps as part of the package
so you know it counts in my book the
weights are the same regardless um
very impressive pull and you can uh you
can check that out in the show notes
you know speaking of straps um i've
gotten my fair share of negative
feedback over the years certainly more
positive than negative like i don't want
to make it seem like i'm
a victim over here getting hassled on
the internet all day
but i'm not sure if i've gotten any
feedback more vitriolic than when i
suggested that strap should be allowed
in powerlifting i i really struck a
nerve with some people on that one
that's interesting because i i say that
a lot
and i've never gotten negative feedback
about that i think i think people just
don't like you that's very that's very
possible
and i don't really disagree with them to
be honest like i don't i'm not a big fan
of me i mean i think there should be a
straps division
yeah yeah and i mean if yeah there
should be
its own division i don't think that it
should just be like hey powerlifting is
now always wearing straps or like
it's straps versus non-straps in the
same division obviously that wouldn't be
a fair
fair way to do it yeah i i think that
one
you know it just offer it would just
offer a different avenue to compete like
dude if you can compete in a multiply
bench shirt you can't tell me that that
is fundamentally altering the movement
of a bench press more than wearing
straps would alter a dead like
the straps can't take away from
any theoretical sanctity of the sport
more than gear would and yeah i'll just
note that's not taking a shot at gear i
think equip power lifting is cool as
hell as we've discussed on the podcast
yeah um but yeah so i i don't see a firm
argument against it and i think it would
uh
i think it would increase the
accessibility of the sport like
uh i i know i know a handful of
middle-aged or older lifters who just
have gotten nerve damage in in one or
both of their arms or hands and so like
you know their their grip is just shot
in one hand and it's like oh cool well i
just i just can't deadlift in
competition anymore so you know i think
a strap division would not harm the
sport i think it would increase the
accessibility of the sport for people
who have like medical reasons for grip
issues
and uh yeah we'd see people hit some
bigger numbers and uh i like big numbers
absolutely so uh
how about uh road to the stage yeah i
don't i don't really have anything to
report um
hit that milestone last week hoping for
hoping for the 50-pound milestone soon
but uh has not happened in the last
calendar week
well there you go
uh road to the athens i actually have a
lot road to the athens
right yeah the road to the athens okay
correct okay road to athens i've got a
lot to say this week
which is different than previous weeks
and it will probably be pretty obvious
why that's the case
um
i've been dealing with
like
pretty substantial pain in my like hip
and pelvis for the last five years
which
you know every time i really get rolling
with a lifting endeavor or a running
endeavor it kind of just always comes
back to get me
five years
bouncing around from specialists to
specialists haven't wanted to talk about
it too much on the show because i think
people only have a a certain amount of
appetite for listening to someone say
hey my hip hurts and i'm not happy about
it
but um anyway it's been five years it's
been really challenging and lately it's
been terrible which is one of the
reasons why i rode to the stage i
haven't had
road to athens i haven't had much to say
because it's like yeah i can't really do
much because my hip hurts like crazy and
i wake up in pain every night
but i want to begin with a huge huge
enormous shout out
to jason yore
he is the physical therapist who's on
our team of coaches at stronger by
science so this might sound like a sales
pitch i simply do not care
uh i am
amazed at jason's skill level so like i
said five years
i keep bouncing from specialists to
specialists i have not gotten an even a
diagnosis let alone a fix like i just
want to know what the deal is well you
have gotten several times oh i've got
yeah
i've gotten you haven't gotten a correct
diagnosis that's a good clarification
i've gotten so many diagnoses none of
which turned out to be even remotely
plausible right and so
at a certain point i just got frustrated
i gave up and then i was in so much pain
i said okay i ungive up because now i'm
frustrated by the pain i go back in
jason finally like just pinned me down
and was like eric what's going on and
like he met he reached out to me on
facebook
i think after three facebook messages
across the span of five minutes he was
like oh yeah this is what's happening
and then i googled it and i'm like oh
yeah that's every symptom i have and no
symptoms i don't have like yeah just
it is what i have right so uh the short
version is i've got a nerve entrapment
issue
and now i'm finally feeling pretty
hopeful and optimistic about exercise
because i feel like
i really have confidence that i know
what's going on
which is the first step to figuring out
okay
so how do i modify my activity find my
entry point for exercise and start
building up function from there and
strengthening what needs to be
strengthened and kind of work from there
uh so i have like a mini coach's corner
about how i'm currently training around
my hip injury
um and so this isn't this is certainly
not medical advice this is just what
i've been doing since getting an idea of
what might be going on and what might be
necessary and these also i should
clarify
jason helped me identify what's going on
and i was like okay cool let's put a pin
in this i'm going to go see an
orthopedic specialist i might get some
imaging done to figure out where the
entrapment is occurring because that
would be very informative so jason did
not give me this advice
in terms of what to do because i
basically said okay let's revisit this
once i consult with this orthopedic
specialist so i'm not
if jason is listening to this and like
yeah that's not what i would have told
you to do
these are not jason's recommendations
these are what i've put together with
just based on how it's feeling
uh so my lower body work right now
almost exclusively focused on just
rehabbing the hip a little bit
strengthening some of the muscle areas
that seem to relieve symptoms and seem
to be very weak relative to others so
i've been doing a lot of
hip flexion
a lot of hip uh
adduction
and i've been avoiding anything that
kind of forces my hip into a fixed
flexed position so any kind of machine
that kind of puts me into deep hip
flexion i've been avoiding that like the
plague trying to keep things uh
a lot of free movement a lot of cable
stuff a lot of free weight stuff that
that is focusing on the hip flexors and
the adductors um lots of machine work
right now even for upper body because
i'm trying to avoid
excessive loading in lumbar flexion
so like even just things like picking up
stuff from like a low uh plate tree like
picking up heavy plates i've been you
know
row machines that aren't particularly
suited for my body shape i've been
avoiding anything that is causing a lot
of loaded flexion a lot of loading on a
flex spine until i can figure out
exactly where the entrapment is because
there is a possibility it could be kind
of closer into the spine like in the
between the the thoracic and lumbar
region so uh i've just been saying like
it's not that i'm not doing any uh
spinal flexion at all
um it's just that i'm being very
intentional about it like if i'm doing
an exercise that involves it that's fine
but i'm trying to just reduce that kind
of mindless wear and tear of just like
bending over awkwardly and picking
things up and doing dumb stuff
uh why are you smiling so much i think
you're going to get some some hate mail
just about using the phrase wear and
tear
okay fine i don't care
uh
i i'm trying to be intentional about my
movement not scared about my movement
you know what i mean so like if i'm
doing stuff that is uh stressing the
spine then i want to be doing it
intentionally with a high degree of
focus on my movement uh it's not that i
think my spine and hip are made out of
glass it's that in this acute phase
until i get
the uh the symptoms to really calm down
and some of that pain to calm down i
don't want to push it too much yet once
those symptoms are are relieved and i
have a little bit more consultation with
the ortho specialist i'm going to have a
lot more confidence determining what
degree of loading is going to be
appropriate so it's just about
that that short term phase of removing
load
so that some of those symptoms go away
then we'll add the load back in once we
identify the appropriate place to kind
of jump back in to some of some of those
types of loading
when it comes to cardio
i forgot a really important lesson
that i was reminded of and that is that
ball is life i'm a hooper now um i
haven't touched a basketball in like 15
years
but uh
for some reason like if i were to go out
on a jog like just endurance type
running
my hip gets really angry with me but i
can actually play basketball pretty okay
just because i think it's because
there's so much movement in different
planes in different directions
and posturally it's a little bit
different uh so i've been playing a lot
of basketball which has been fun uh have
not rediscovered my shot yet or my
dribbling ability but i'm sure that will
come with time
uh my gym has a very cool machine it's a
rope climber have you ever seen those
yeah yeah it's i've been really loving
it i've been trying to find upper body
modalities for cardio uh and i've been
really enjoying that a lot uh and i've
been doing doing a lot of swimming as
well so it's
it's really unique like i've noticed
that my hip flexors are extremely weak
but swimming is cool because you can do
a lot of hip flexion with a little bit
of resistance from the water just to
kind of build up the endurance of the
hip flexors with a relatively short
range of motion which for me right now
is very good like i want my hip and my
spine to be moving i just want to be
intentional with how much they're being
loaded and in what ways they're being
loaded so uh there's certainly no fear
of exercise and in fact a complete
cessation of exercise actually makes
symptoms worse for me or
it's like doing a little is better than
doing nothing but doing too much is
worse than everything you know so i'm
trying to find that sweet spot where i'm
moving and you know getting my spine
moving getting my hip moving
enjoying exercise but not pushing it too
hard and for now i found a sweet spot
and
i'll probably revisit this list and kind
of refine it once i have a better
understanding of exactly what's going on
and where that nerve entrapment is
occurring
uh and i'll get with you know jason and
some other folks and figure out what to
do but for now uh the road to athens is
looking positive i'm obviously not doing
a lot of endurance running but i'm doing
exercise that will benefit me once i'm
able to resume higher volume endurance
running so very exciting time i'm really
stoked about it well sounds good i'm i'm
excited for you uh
just from talking off air i know that
this is something that's been bothering
you
really for as long as i've known you um
so it's it's good to hear that
it sounds like like
real progress is being made and there is
the potential for uh substantially
greater progress to be made yeah so i
said wear and tear we we nipped that in
the bud is there anything else i need to
get ahead of here to avoid the hate mail
because you're more you're more in
in tune with this stuff than i am um
let's see so one thing to potentially
get ahead of is now that i know you're
playing basketball again we're gonna
have to go put up shots as soon as we're
done recording this uh and so you might
need to start weaving a narrative about
how badly you got beaten horse and and
maybe weave a conspiracy theory about
there being a setup that i only beat you
so badly because it's a goal that i'm
comfortable shooting on like there's the
hoop that you shoot on is 9 feet and 10
inches tall and i shoot on a regulation
10-foot hoop
so that's done yeah so so good work you
you you're already weaving the necessary
narratives to save face so yeah just uh
just be stewing on that a little bit
more um so you so that you'll be able to
discuss it in a self-flattering way uh
during our next episode perfect yeah and
it was good that you called me out
because wear and tear is kind of just
like a
a standard kind of verbal crutch you
know but but obviously
bodies adapt to movement they adapt to
movement very well but but right now i
am in that kind of you know when it
comes to rehabilitating from an injury
there's kind of the acute phase and then
the more chronic phase and during the
acute phase you know a big portion is
just like
stopping the things that seem to be
exacerbating symptoms yeah and so right
now i'm almost taking the exercise
approach of like
you know i'm more the nutrition guy you
hear about like an elimination diet
where you're like okay
i have some kind of gi [ __ ] going on
right now that's not good let me tighten
up my list and start experimenting with
foods and see what is bothering it
and so my whole thing is i want to get
to a spot where all of my loading is
very intentional
and very thoughtful so that i can start
to see
okay like that that type of loading on
the spine is is hurting this type is not
for now and you know we build up from
there like i have no doubt that in the
future i'll be squatting and deadlifting
very comfortably like i'm quite
confident about that um but it's all
about finding your entry point and then
building up from there with that with
movement and exercise and i want to make
sure that there's no ambiguity about
like what exactly is causing these
symptoms you know yeah so so that's kind
of what i'm getting at there
uh all right so moving on
we've got uh a segment that we've done
on the show before we don't do it very
often because
we don't write enough articles
it's uh stronger by science article
discussion that is the segment type and
we did put up an article fairly recently
which is called building muscle in a
caloric deficit
and then a colon context is key
so this is an article that was pulled
from the pages of the mass research
review and republished on stronger by
science but if you go to
science dot com slash muscle calorie or
muscle caloric deficit you can find this
new article
and i did want to take a moment to talk
a little bit about this article because
it is featured in the best of mass issue
so uh this article largely received uh
some some pretty positive feedback i
think it's a topic that a lot of people
are interested in these days because
there are
two camps that seem to be forming there
there's the one camp that says
if you try to build muscle and lose fat
at the same time
you are wasting your time because you're
chasing two rabbits at once and when you
try to chase two things at the same time
you usually don't catch either of them
so a lot of people like to
suggest that you have to focus on
building muscle
or focus on losing fat and do those
sequentially in whatever order you
choose
but a lot of people say listen
there are maybe like four or five
unicorns out there who can achieve
recomposition building muscle losing fat
at the same time but it's so rare as to
consider just off the table as a
a
viable option for your for your planning
now i take a different approach i think
that
recomposition is a lot more feasible
than than some would lead you to believe
and ultimately uh it comes down to the
characteristics of the individual right
so uh yeah if you were to ask me what is
the way to absolutely maximize my rate
of muscle building it wouldn't be to be
in a caloric deficit right but um so so
looking at it
on that level of course if you want to
build muscle easiest way to do it lift
like crazy eat like crazy gain a bunch
of fat and muscle in the process just
eat to your heart's content you are
going to not leave any anabolic stone
unturned but obviously then there's some
fat gain associated and sometimes people
say well then i have to cut after that
right
again if you wanted to maximize your
rate of fat loss it would be you know
protein sparing modified fast begin it
yesterday and just go with it you know
until you get to your desired body fat
not a very sustainable approach you may
threaten the loss of lean mass i know
it's called protein sparing but that's
more of a goal than a than a descriptor
it's an aspirational statement yeah um
so like
the question is can we feasibly try to
do both these things at once and i think
for a large number of people the answer
is yes and like for example uh sometimes
people just boil it down purely to how
many years have you been training and
they're like you know what if you've
been training for more than three years
you cannot recomp i've been training
since i was 12. i'm 31 that's a lot of
years it's more than three i guarantee i
could recomp right now right with all
the stuff i've been dealing with with my
hip i have been training but not
not training to an optimal degree you
know there's no question in my mind i
could tighten up my diet and training
right now and achieve a pretty
noteworthy degree of recomposition i i
have no question about that um so what i
try to do in this article i was
reviewing a study
so i started out by reviewing the study
and then i talked a little bit more
about
who could feasibly achieve recomposition
in what circumstances and how would they
go about doing that and so with this
particular article i focused mostly on
just
manipulating rates of weight gain and
weight loss or manipulating energy
balance so i didn't go into every
little detail about what promotes muscle
building or what promotes fat loss i
kept it focused on energy balance and
rate of weight change basically
uh so let's start out with with uh the
study here so
um
there was a meta-analysis here that was
let me find who was it by it was by
murphy and colleagues in 2021
it was called energy deficiency impairs
resistance training gains in lean mass
but not strength a meta-analysis and
meta regression and if you go to the
article on stronger by science the
original meta-analysis is linked there
as well
so what they were looking at is the
impact of an energy deficit on trainee's
ability ability to gain strength and
build lean mass in response to
resistance training
and the short version of what they found
is that energy deficits
did lead to significant impairment of
lean mass gains
and a non-significant impairment of
strength gains
what they found was that basically
being in a deficit seemed to impact
lean mass changes a lot more than it
impacted strength changes
and they found that this was dependent
on the size of the deficit so as the
energy deficit grew by a hundred
calories a day
lean mass tended to drop by .031
units and that unit is going to seem
very arbitrary but what that
basically uh alludes to within the paper
is that once the deficit got to a level
of about 500 calories per day that was
predicted based on the meta-regression
model to fully blunt lean mass gains
now that is not a rule of nature like
that is not a physical law that a 500
calorie per day deficit
fully removes your ability to gain lean
mass that is just a characteristic of
the data set and the regression model
used to fit that data set so it's really
important to keep that in mind
i think if you open up the article if
you have an opportunity to look at it i
think the really telling things the
really informative things come in figure
2 and figure 3 within my article
not the original paper so figure 2
basically shows a whole bunch of
different effect sizes study by study
and they look at training with an energy
deficit versus training without an
energy deficit and they look at uh
changes in lean mass and changes in
strength in in both scenarios
and what's what really jumps out to you
is
when you look at training without an
energy deficit
the change in strength at the group
level in all these different studies uh
pretty consistently goes up right people
get stronger when they do resistance
training and they're not in an energy
deficit and the pretty much the same
thing was observed in the studies with
an energy deficit like there was
one maybe two studies that showed a
slight group level decrease in strength
but
the vast majority of studies it didn't
really look like the deficit did much in
terms of impairing strength gains and
that makes a lot of sense greg you've
done a lot of really good writing about
all the various factors that contribute
to changes in strength and when we look
at you know something like a short term
8 10 12 week study with a really focused
strength training program you do not
need
participants to build substantial
amounts of muscle in order to get
stronger there are many other factors
influencing strength gains across that
type of of timeline yeah over like three
months the amount of muscle you build
isn't going to be particularly
predictive of strength gains but over
10 years the amount of muscle you build
will probably be pretty predictive right
and you know this was largely looking at
some of those short-term studies your
kind of classic resistance training
control trial
now things look a little different in
that figure when you look at changes in
lean mass so when you look at changes in
lean mass in training without an energy
deficit again changes were either you
know not much was happening sometimes we
see that in a lifting trial people get
stronger and lean mass just kind of
stays the same pre to post
generally speaking lean mass either
didn't change or it went up i don't
think there were any studies at the
group level that reported a negative
change in lean mass uh that was not the
case when you when they looked at
studies where people were training with
an energy deficit there were actually
actually more than half of the studies
reported a group level decrease in lean
mass
now how much lean mass you lose
over
the course of a resistance training
program of course there are a ton of
factors that go into that um but but
without question this study or this
meta-analysis showed that in aggregate
you know certainly training in an energy
deficit
makes it more of an uphill battle to
gain lean mass not necessarily
impossible but it does have some degree
of hindrance or impairment when it comes
to building lean mass
but you know these are kind of your
typical resistance training controlled
trials there it's very different from
working one-on-one with the coach and
saying let's tailor everything to
optimize lean mass retention during this
cut you know usually they're pretty
generic programs pretty generic diet
advice
not individualized and hyper-specific
programming that is
optimized and tailored to to optimally
impact lean mass
figure three is another interesting
thing here so
figure three plots on the x-axis
the size of the energy deficit ranging
from you know zero calories per day all
the way up to 1500 actually a little bit
above 1500 calories per day which is a
damn that's a big that's a big deficit
that's not fun no um
and then on the y-axis there's changes
in lean mass expressed as effect size
units so basically uh you know
standardized uh mean change
and what was interesting about this is
like i said they fit a meta regression
line to this data which crossed zero at
500 calories per day which indicates a
deficit of 500 calories per day was
predicted to result in zero change in
lean mass deficits larger than that were
predicted to actually yield a reduction
in lean mass
but as you can see from the data if you
look at the the figure if you happen to
pull it up uh it's kind of like when we
talk about that uh meta-analysis or the
meta-regression about protein intake by
morton and colleagues where it's like we
can identify a break point but when you
look at the individual data points you
do not see a dramatic area where numbers
just fall off a cliff like it's not like
everybody was doing just fine and then
they hit 500 calories per day and you
know lean mass gains tanked it's a
little bit
messier than that so like for example
the second highest effect size the
second largest effect size um you know
it was actually uh or actually let me
take that back
the basic point is that there's not a
clear drop off you know it's
as there's definitely a relationship
here as the deficit gets bigger lean
mass changes uh are harder and harder to
come by and so what that means is if
you're trying to achieve recomposition
you want to keep that general
relationship in mind you don't want to
use that 500 number as a
law of physics you know it because that
would be just not at all reflective of
the certainty of that number
but you definitely want to keep in mind
the fact that
if you're trying to build muscle while
you're losing fat you're going to be in
an energy deficit and the larger that
deficit gets the more challenging it
becomes to kind of thread that needle
and achieve appreciable increases in
lean mass while you're achieving that
fat loss along the way so uh ultimately
my conclusion after looking at this
meta-analysis and some uh some of the
related research is
uh
recomposition is certainly possible uh
and for a lot of people probably more
than you think it is a feasible goal um
and it
you are making some degree of sacrifice
when you set out to do recomposition
you're kind of
accepting on the front end yeah i
probably could gain lean mass faster if
i were
in neutral or positive energy balance
but what you're trying to do there is uh
you know kind of find that sweet spot
where you're gaining lean mass at a rate
that you're still happy with while also
losing fat mass along the way it can be
a very convenient convenient and very
time efficient way to make some pretty
dramatic body composition change without
having to feel like you are fully locked
into one route versus the other um so
if you check out the article you'll see
that in the there's kind of a practical
application section where i go into
detail about how you would adjust energy
balance for a variety of different goals
and the way that i tried to quantify
that i think the most
straightforward and simple way to
quantify that
navigation of energy balance or the
manipulation of energy balance is just
by looking at change in body mass so the
rate of weekly or monthly weight gain or
the rate of weekly or monthly weight
loss you know i think that's the easiest
way to look at it and i don't want to go
through and read every possible
permutation here because the most likely
scenario is i'll just get some numbers
jumbled and then cause more confusion
so to get a look at it so i go through
in detail
how would you adjust your rate of weight
gain or rate of
rate of weight loss if you're training
specifically for strength or
specifically for recomposition or
specifically for hypertrophy or
specifically for fat loss and so there
are some slightly uh different
guidelines for each of those different
scenarios
and i also
in the process of giving those
guidelines i address the fact that your
training age or or your relative
training status is an important factor
that modifies how quickly you want to
gain or lose some weight so
if you have an opportunity i definitely
recommend that you check out that
article to get some of that
[Music]
kind of goal specific advice about what
rate of weight loss or rate of weight
gain would be right for you based on
what you're trying to achieve
but but the general kind of take home
point is
a lot of people say that recomposition
is either impossible or just simply not
feasible and for a large percentage of
lifters i think that that's simply not
true i think it is possible and indeed
is actually feasible um it's especially
true if you've got plenty of body fat to
lose and you're relatively untrained in
that situation there's a very high
likelihood that you can get in an energy
deficit that is large enough to get the
ball rolling in terms of fat loss
without dramatically impairing your
ability to get stronger or build muscle
now if you are shredded you're near your
genetic ceiling in terms of strength and
muscularity
in that situation
i i will concede that you know dramatic
recomposition is probably a bit of a
long shot
and that really gets at something that
we mentioned back when we were talking
about uh
when we were talking about the
interference effect you know we had
mentioned that like generally speaking
it doesn't seem too scary but like if
you are just absolutely at your genetic
limit for muscularity and you are just
infinitely well trained in terms of
muscularity and hypertrophy
then you might want to it might be a
more notable thing like if you're super
specifically optimized for one
particular outcome
then yeah adding in a ton of cardio
might might move the needle a little bit
more
um or you know if you are
on on the on the flip side
if you are
really really really really super well
trained for endurance training and then
you shift things and and kind of reduce
some of your endurance training and add
in more lifting if you're not careful
about using those really carefully then
you might you might be losing something
by sacrificing some of that endurance
training because you are already kind of
at a peak like you have really optimized
your training adaptations but uh you
know for most of us especially when it
comes to this recomposition conversation
i think a large percentage of people are
somewhere in the middle you know where
they're not
absolutely shredded and as muscular as
they're ever going to be most people are
kind of in that middle range where
they're like yeah i could probably stand
to
lose a little bit of body fat and i'm
def i definitely have some room to go
before i reach my muscular potential for
a lot of people i think recomposition is
is a pretty feasible thing to shoot for
and in the article i kind of lay out uh
how you would set your your target rate
of weight change in order to make that
feasible cool yeah so i have uh just
just one thing to add about this so um
so
i
used to believe back in the day that it
was uh impossible or virtually
impossible to gain muscle in a
uh even like a small caloric deficit uh
if if you weren't just completely
untrained
and then
maybe like four or five years ago uh
eric helms and lawrence judd wrote an
article that uh in part what it was
talking about was uh the feasibility of
of recomposition like this
simultaneously losing some fat gaining
some muscle uh and i remember reading
that and being like okay like this
this article makes a pretty good case
for
for being able to gain muscle in a
caloric deficit being something that is
possible
so at that point i looked back and i was
like okay
what what arguments
against this did i previously find
convincing like when when i had
previously been exposed to the viewpoint
that it was impossible to gain muscle in
a caloric deficit if you had
any sort of prior training experience um
you know what what was the evidence and
line of reasoning backing that up and it
was basically two things uh one
is uh is people would cite studies with
trained lifters training in an energy
deficit they lose some weight and you
know they um like their their lean mass
uh
there wasn't a significant change but
like nominally it was a decrease it
would be like you know a reduction of
0.5 plus or minus 0.7 kilos and they're
like oh look like these guys
lost a little bit of lean mass and it's
like oh
guess what standard deviations exist
like a third of these people did gain at
least some trivial amount of lean mass
so you know i i was uh reading that
content before i understood what a
standard deviation was uh in in
hindsight it is
embarrassing that i found that
convincing and embarrassing that people
would write those articles in the first
place uh and and exposed to the world
that they also uh did not know what a
standard deviation was and second the
the just kind of like rationalist line
of argumentation would be like well look
you know um
you're not just like inertly storing
energy in muscles like it takes energy
to synthesize these proteins so if
you're not putting enough energy into
your body there's not going to be enough
energy to synthesize these new
contractile proteins therefore it's
impossible to gain muscle
and it's like okay let's let's stop
let's rewind let's think about this for
a second uh if
if being in an energy deficit meant that
you did not have sufficient energy to
synthesize new proteins
that would mean that you just die like
you you uh turn over your entire red
blood cell pool if memory serves like
once a month so it's like oh [ __ ] man i
don't have enough
i'm not in an energy surplus so i don't
have energy to synthesize new proteins
therefore
every time i need to make some more
[ __ ] hemoglobin for my red blood
cells i just can't i can't do it there's
there's no extra energy lying around to
do it i can't turn turn over my body's
proteins anymore i guess being in a
deficit for a month means you die which
is you just like become severely anemic
and you will never heal a wound exactly
so like obviously that doesn't happen
and so it's like well okay if if that
line of thinking doesn't apply to
any other proteins in your body why
would it necessarily apply to
contractile proteins in your muscles you
know yeah definitely so
anyway i i kind of had that that come to
jesus moment several years ago and
realize that the
you know the the evidence does suggest
that it is
quite a bit harder to build muscle in a
deficit and you you certainly won't
build as much but the arguments
the arguments and evidence
that people will marshal to argue that
it is impossible to build muscle in a
deficit it's just thin gruel like it's
it's lazy thinking and weak evidence
absolutely yeah it's you're you're not
gonna you're unlikely to optimize your
rate of muscle gain or lean mass gain in
a deficit but appreciable lean mask gain
absolutely can occur and the reason i
say that is because it's been documented
in the research many many times it's one
of the few things that i
still hear as being impossible sometimes
and i'm like
i can i can just show you where it
happened yeah like you know it's odd the
way that people will
matter effectively say that it's
impossible
i can't think of something that is so
frequently asserted as being impossible
that has so much empirical evidence
showing that it occurred you know
but anyway uh
one other thing i should mention um
on this topic a lot of times people say
okay so
uh caloric surplus is good for building
muscle how much is enough and
unfortunately we really don't know um
i'm not aware of really good evidence
indicating you know theoretically there
should probably be some degree of
diminishing returns where you know
at a certain point the the kind of cost
benefit of a bigger caloric surplus it's
just like all right you're just you're
gaining a tremendous amount of fat mass
relative to your lean mass you've pretty
much maxed out the benefit there we
don't really know where that is so a lot
of times the question of how high to go
with a surplus if you're just purely
intent on bulking is like
pretty much what's your comfort level
with fat gain um and and how big of a
hurry are you in if you're in a huge
hurry then that would kind of push you
toward a higher surplus in terms of
building muscle uh but if you're very
averse to gaining fat then that would
push you to a to a smaller surplus for
now that's kind of the best we can do
all right greg i'm going to turn things
over to you i know you've got a lot to
cover with your half of the best of
issue and then if if we have some time
left over i'll just briefly run through
my other contributions cool all right so
uh i've got five things i want to talk
about and if you've listened to this
podcast before you know that if i'm
trying to cover five pieces of content
there's a good chance that's going to
run like an hour and a half so i'm going
to try to scoot and uh and be as
efficient as possible
so
my first article in the best of issue
the title is a heuristic for estimating
energy expenditure during resistance
training
and the title of the study this came
from
was
uh
acute behavior of oxygen consumption
lactate concentrations energy and energy
expenditure during resistance training
colon comparisons across three
intensities by zhao and colleagues
and so uh what this study did in essence
is um it helps us answer
a practical question that there's
surprisingly surprisingly little direct
research on and surprisingly few good
heuristics about and that is attempting
to estimate how much energy you burn
during resistance training
and so the reason that this is a problem
is that if you are someone who for
whatever reason wants to attempt to
quantify how much energy you're burning
during exercise there are
uh good reliable heuristics for
endurance training so
the the old chestnut of you burn about
100 calories per mile you traverse if
you're walking or jogging that holds up
pretty well
if you're a serious cyclist you can just
get a power meter for your bike and then
just use some assumptions about your
your gross energy efficiency to kind of
get an idea of how much energy you're
burning on on the bike
but when it comes to resistance training
there aren't good heuristics and you
know if you use a wearable device to try
to estimate your your energy expenditure
during exercise the research shows very
consistently that uh
like smart watches fitbits stuff like
that do do a really poor job of
estimating your your energy expenditure
and there aren't good heuristics like
that you know like uh 100 calories per
mile like okay
but
you know what is my energy expenditure
per
uh unit of tonnage or per unit of time
spent in the gym um as far as i'm aware
there aren't good heuristics for that so
this study i think uh helps us at least
get a decent ballpark answer to that
question so in this study uh they've
recruited 15 trained men and all of them
went through three different workouts
two sets of 15 3 sets of 10 and 6 sets
of 5
for like 9 or 10 different exercises in
a full body resistance training session
so so three different sessions performed
in a randomized order
they did some chest press pec decks
squat lat pull downs
bicep curls tricep extensions hamstring
curls and crunches uh so
they they always had two minutes of rest
between sets
and they um
they wore a mask the whole time to
measure gas exchange to estimate total
energy expenditure during the sessions
uh and so so the researchers were
interested in
uh total energy expenditure during the
sessions and then also energy
expenditure per unit of time
and the the six sets of five
session uh obviously people were doing
more sets during that with with a higher
total load but most importantly just
more sets so those sessions took the
longest uh and unsurprisingly wound up
resulting in the total uh the highest
total energy expenditure largely just
because when they're measuring gas
exchange uh that includes you know
during rest periods as well so
your body's burning some amount of
energy just to stay alive uh and so you
know if you're measuring energy
expenditure over a longer total duration
more total energy will be burned but
then when they expressed uh all three
workouts in terms of energy expenditure
per minute they were all very similar
and what they saw is that across all
three workouts at different training
intensities different uh different
amounts of reps per sets
all three of those workouts resulted in
on average about six kilocalories being
burned per minute uh and with a
relatively tight range as well from
about four to about eight kilocalories
per minute
so i think that gives us a decent
heuristic
uh that people in the gym are burning
probably somewhere in the neighborhood
of about six calories per minute and
then when i thought about when i thought
about it a little bit more i i like
the idea
uh so
i i like the idea of that being an
estimate and being kind of a
self-correcting estimate uh in most
contexts so first just kind of to pass
the the sanity check like does six
kilocalories per minute seem to make
sense so you can compare that to
uh something that is much better
understood so energy expenditure um
during uh during endurance training or
just walking and basically six cal
kilocalories per minute would equate to
walking at about 3.6 miles per hour or
like a 16 17 minute mile
which which feels about right um it's a
brisk walk yeah yeah so like a brisk
walking pace
uh burning about as much energy as a
resistance training session that that
feels about right to me so you know
during a training session like obviously
like maybe you do a hard set of squats
that's obviously very energy intensive
but then you're gonna rest and and by
the end of your rest interval before
your next set uh you've probably like
calmed down to the point that like now
whatever you're experiencing is is an
intensity of uh metabolic and
respiratory output that's way lower than
it would be for walking and so it you
know it undulates but over the course of
a session can i see resistance training
being about as energy intensive as a
brisk walk yeah i think so so that that
passes the sanity check
um
and then in terms of it being
self-correcting
like if you're doing
if you're doing like really
heavy high volume training so we've
talked about this on the podcast before
um
the amount of energy you burn resistance
training uh scales
quite well with the total amount of just
physical work being performed so if you
squat uh 200 pounds for a set of 10
you're burning about as a third as much
energy as someone who's squatting 600
pounds for a set of 10 like you're
if anyone who's strong enough to do 600
for 10 you're [ __ ] dead at the end of
it uh whereas you know if 200 for 10 is
is your 10 rep max you're probably
breathing hard at the end but you're
you're not very close to meeting your
maker um and that's just because there's
a huge
difference in energy expenditure but
then on the flip side
you're gonna rest way longer after that
set of 10 at 600 pounds versus maybe
getting back under the bar a minute two
minutes later after the 200 for a set of
10. so basically the more energy
intensive the sets you're doing are just
kind of naturally the longer you're
going to rest uh on the back side of it
um so i think that it's uh i think that
it's something that does self-regulate
pretty well where
you we can probably assume that most
people
over the course of an entire session are
probably burning energy at a somewhat
comparable rate probably dependent to
some degree on just their overall level
of aerobic fitness with people who are
more fit just resting shorter amounts of
time on average than people who are less
heroically fit but there there is kind
of that inbuilt regulatory mechanism in
place
um
and so yeah i i do think that that seems
like a pretty decent uh heuristic to
roll with um
it is worth noting that it that it does
probably break down for certain types of
workouts so you know if you're doing a
workout that's just
like
10 singles and you're resting 10 minutes
between each single to make sure you're
fully recovered yeah you're probably not
burning six calories per minute
or if you're doing like a high intensity
interval training circuit specifically
for the purpose of of trying to make
your resistance training as
metabolically challenging as possible
it's probably going to be above kind of
that top end of this estimated range of
about four to eight kilocalories per
minute so you know
there there are types of workouts for
which this heuristic probably doesn't
apply but for most just kind of like
normal uh resistance training workouts
it's probably gonna get you in the right
general ballpark um so
uh
and one other thing to note is the six
kilocalories per minute that's an
estimation of total energy expenditure
not uh
not additive energy expenditure so some
proportion of that is just going to be
the energy you're burning just to keep
yourself alive like your basal
metabolism
so we can also estimate the
the additive uh part of that energy
expenditure um there's there's a
generalized equation that i provided
in the article that you can use to do
that by hand but i also made a handy
little calculator in google sheets that
the article links to that you can check
out uh if this is something you would
you would like to uh use for yourself to
estimate energy expenditure in your own
training
so one of the things that i think is
really nice is that you can look at
you know estimated
resting energy expenditure and then you
could use this kind of heuristic and so
even for the some of those types of
exercises you mentioned that might be
higher than than this number might be
lower you can still use those two
numbers to get like a ballpark kind of
range like yeah yeah okay like here's
resting here's like a standard number
for resistance training i was doing a
bunch of singles with a ton of rest so
i'm kind of somewhere
in that middle range and you can kind of
feel out you know where you want to put
that estimate yeah yeah
um
so yeah that that was uh my first
article in the best of issue
moving on i had a
i reviewed a study called uh
understanding bench press biomechanics
training expertise and sex effect
lifting technique and net joint moments
by mauser hunt and crosshog
um so this study
was in my my title for this article was
bench press may target different muscles
in male and female lifters and so
essentially what this study did is
they they were interested in seeing
whether sex and training experience
would affect um both both joint moments
and muscle activation in the bench press
and so what they did is they recruited
uh one cohort of recreationally trained
lifters and one cohort of competitive
power lifters with male and female
subjects in both cohorts
and and they basically just had them do
a single set of bench press with a six
to eight rm load and they attached uh
reflective markers to their joints into
the bar so they could estimate uh joint
moments about the shoulder and about the
elbow and they also put emg electrodes
on the front delt the triceps and the
pecs to get a rough idea of of muscle
emg which uh is a proxy for excitation
of those muscles being assessed and they
were basically just interested in
whether
male and female lifters had different
overall patterns of joint moments and
muscle emg and whether competitive
uh power lifters versus just
recreationally trained subjects had uh
different patterns of joint moments and
emg
and for for this article i mostly
focused
on the uh on the sex differences um so
so uh competitive category seemed like
it may have an effect um but that seemed
like it was potentially just secondary
to bar path so
both the
uh the the male and female power lifters
seem to adopt a different technique than
the recreationally trained subjects
which would be pretty predictable so the
the power lifters they had more uh
horizontal barbell displacement
basically they touch lower on their
chest
versus like a more linear bar path for
the the recreationally trained subjects
and so there were some differences
downstream of that but i think that's
more just reflective of technique
differences than than differences in
training experience
uh but as far as the sex comparisons go
it seemed that the female benchers
regardless of of competitive category
had a more triceps dominant bench and
the male benchers had a more peck
dominant bench and that showed up both
in the emg data and in the the joint
moment data
so the
the ratio of elbow to shoulder net joint
moments was kind of more tilted toward
elbow joint moments in the female
lifters more tilted towards shoulder
joint moments in the male lifters and
then as far as the emg data goes uh
there there was higher pec emg in the
male ventures higher triceps emg in the
female ventures so that that tells a
a cohesive story so the emg data and the
joint kinetic data match up pretty well
suggesting that for
benching with heavy but still sub
maximal loads maybe female benchers are
relying on their triceps a bit more and
male benchers are relying on their pecs
a bit more on average
which which was an interesting finding
and it also paired nicely with a prior
study by
kroll and golus that we've reviewed i
think like three years ago in mass so in
that study what they did is they were
also looking at emg in the bench press
and they were looking at how it changed
with increasing loads from if memory
serves
55 percent of 1rm up to 1rm loads and
what they found in that study is that
the
increase in
pec emg from
very sub maximal loads 55 of 1rm up to
1rm loads the increases in pec emg were
larger in female lifters than male
lifters and the increase in triceps emg
was larger in male lifters than female
lifters and so at first those these two
studies might seem contradictory so the
the study in the best of issue found
that oh maybe the bench press is a
little bit more triceps dominant for
women a little bit more peck dominant
for men the prior study by krolan golus
found that ooh maybe
the the pec emg increases more towards
maximal loads for females but triceps
emg is increasing more as you approach
maximal load in males so how do those
two things uh
mesh like they seem contradictory but i
actually think they match up pretty
nicely i think that they suggest
that when you're benching with with
sub-maximal load so just kind of like
normal standard training loads maybe the
bench press is a slightly more triceps
dominant lift for females on average and
slightly more pec dominant for males on
average
but
that's not necessarily reflective of
uh like just
inherent sex differences in the ability
to
access and use those muscles basically
uh
what what i put forth as a potential
explanation to explain how these studies
mesh
is that essentially
the the nervous system for for female
lifters may just kind of like lean on
the triceps a little bit more for kind
of like normal work but then there's
still a strength reserve in the pecs so
when when lifts approach maximal
intensity that's kind of the last safety
valve to to ramp up and and
you know carry the load as the loads get
very very heavy and the opposite being
true for the triceps so uh for for male
lifters so you know maybe with sub
maximal training loads the the nervous
system and male lifters wants to lean
more on the pecs but then as the loads
get really heavy and the pecs are
basically tapped out you still have that
strength reserve and the triceps to kind
of uh carry the additional load as the
loads approach maximal uh so i i thought
this was interesting i did find it uh
i found it neat that both of these
studies suggested that there might be
some
some neuromuscular differences between
the sexes in terms of what muscles are
relied on more heavily
even in even in an exercise that's as
relatively simple as the bench press and
one other thing to note um
so
you may have been listening to this and
heard like oh well this study found that
uh you know higher elbow joint moments
relative to shoulder joint moments and
the female lifters maybe that was just
due to differences in grip width that
the lifters chose i should have
mentioned this on the front end uh grip
width was standardized in this study so
it was 100 or 160 percent of biochromial
breadth for all of the subjects so you
you can't just chalk these these
differences up to
uh self-selected grip with differences
it does seem to be
uh i guess like true differences in the
the movement strategies that the lifters
select and maybe neuromuscular
activation patterns that the nervous
system selects
cool
it sounds good any feedback on that one
uh
bench hard you know that's kind of how i
do it
cool um
all right moving on my next
article my my title for it was
attentional focus may influence strength
development and it was a review of the
study
uh
acute and long-term effects of
attentional focus strategies on muscular
strength uh colon a meta-analysis by
gurgic and colleagues and so uh yeah
this was a meta-analysis
on attentional focus and so
i know we've talked about attentional
focus on the podcast before but i'm sure
it's been a while because i can't
remember when the last time was but
basically um
an internal attentional focus is a focus
on some component of a movement and so
um
most often in the term
in the context of lifting when you think
about an internal attentional focus it's
generally like focusing on
feeling a particular muscle working or
contracting so you know if you're doing
bicep curls instead of just trying to to
maximize performance on bicep curls
you're really focusing on squeezing the
biceps feeling it get a good contraction
that's an internal attentional focus
versus an external attentional focus
that's a focus on the outcome of a
movement so
you know in the case of bicep curls
you're not necessarily trying to feel
your biceps get the best contraction
possible you're you're you have a weight
in your hands and you're trying to
uppercut someone as explosively as
possible with it um
and sometimes like the way i think about
it when i'm doing a machine based
movement right is like maybe you're
doing something like rows or pull-downs
and a lot of people have difficulty even
implementing internal focus when they're
doing lat movements like a lot of people
really struggle to make that mind muscle
connection sometimes i just kind of
focus on the stack and just watch the
stack go up and down and i'm just
thinking drive the elbows back and just
get that stack up yeah
um so yeah i think probably the
the external cue
that people in powerlifting would be the
most familiar with is in bench press
just throw the bar through the ceiling
that's a that's a classic external cue
um so yeah those those are kind of the
broad differences in internal versus
external attentional focus strategies
and what this meta-analysis wanted to do
is look at the evidence related to the
impact of internal versus external
attentional focus on acute strength
performance but then also
changes
longitudinal changes in strength and
performance over time
um
and so
in terms of the acute meta-analysis they
came up with one two three four five six
seven
eight uh eight studies i i think it was
eight uh different groups and seven
studies um looking at the impact of
internal versus external attentional
focus on strength performance and they
found that an external attentional focus
did uh improve strength performance
relative to an internal focus which
isn't surprising that is what one would
predict
but it is actually good to see and the
reason i say that
is
most of the research on intentional
focus
isn't hyper specific to strength
outcomes so there's a really really
broad body of research on internal
versus external intentional focus on
performance and acute neuromuscular
outcomes but most of it is more looking
at
uh things like jump height which is
somewhat related to maximal strength
performance but then also more just kind
of like fine motor skills so or i guess
this would be more like gross motor
skills but like bean bag tossing so you
know do you focus on
the the the
like pendulum arc of your arm as you
toss the bean bag which would be an
internal focus or do you just kind of
like stare at the target where you want
to toss the bean bag and and to focus on
the outcome of the movement like that um
and so there's there's a lot of uh
just kind of like neuromuscular research
looking at sort of like accuracy based
goals finding that external attentional
focus
produces better outcomes but like i said
a lot of that isn't isn't directly
related to strength performance but
there's now enough research looking at
the acute impact of internal versus
external attentional focus
on maximal strength performance that we
can meta-analyze these studies and find
that yeah an external attentional focus
acutely enhances strength performance
not you know it's not gonna like double
your bench press but the pooled effect
size was like .3.4 something like that
so that's a that's a small but notable
effect um
then in terms of
longitudinal outcomes there were only
three studies that could be included in
this meta-analysis
um
so you know
regardless of what they found
and regardless of the fact that that
it's a meta-analysis uh statistical
power and meta-analysis is still a thing
you can have a meta-analysis that is
underpowered and no matter what this
meta found it would have probably been
underpowered um
so you know we don't want to put
all of our eggs in this basket but they
they did two separate metas here they
they looked at the effect uh of internal
versus external attentional focus on all
strength measures included in in the
studies uh that made this meta-analysis
and they also looked at the impact of
internal versus external attentional
focus just on lower body strength
measures and they found that when
looking at all strength measures there
was kind of an aggregate nominal
positive effect
for external attentional focus on
strength gains over time that wasn't
quite statistically significant
but for
just lower body measures of strength
development they found that an external
attentional focus
did have a statistically significant
effect on strength development over time
uh and
the difference between the analysis of
all strength outcomes versus just lower
body strength outcomes i think it was
just uh so there was a 2018 schoenfeld
study which
if you've ever listened to people talk
about the the impact of internal versus
external attentional focus on
hypertrophy this is the study they'll
they'll always bring up um
and in that study they found that an
internal attentional focus
was beneficial for biceps growth didn't
really seem to do all that much for quad
growth but people really just focus on
the biceps findings and they're like oh
yeah like really focusing on squeezing
getting that good biceps contraction
that's going to help you grow more
internal attentional focus
very evidence-based scientifically
validated for hypertrophy the outcomes
of that study that aren't talked about
as much are the strength outcomes and in
that study uh an internal attentional
focus was also beneficial for increases
in bicep strength whereas every other
study that has looked at this has found
that an external attentional focus
is
superior for strength development so
basically what this meta found is that
when you pull
all of the measures from these three
studies together there's not a
statistically significant effect of uh
attentional focus on strength
development but if you just kind of
throw out the biceps findings in in the
schoenfeld study uh in external
attentional focus does have a
statistically significant effect on
strength development uh so basically
it's it's a finding that is
that seems to be completely contingent
on whether or not you include one
measure from one study so as i mentioned
before
underpowered meta-analysis uh but it
does at least suggest that the bulk of
the evidence kind of leans in favor of
an external attentional focus
probably enhancing strength development
over time and that's an important thing
because
you know one of the things we talk about
on the podcast a lot
is that there are
a lot of acute studies that find that
you know some supplement or some
training practice uh acutely enhances
performance and training or testing a
little bit but then the big question is
like well if you if you do this all the
time and you always take this supplement
before training or you always use this
warm-up practice that enhances
performance a little bit
does that actually improve
strength gains and performance more over
time than not doing that thing so you
know we would like to assume that
anything that acutely enhances
performance will also
chronically lead to larger performance
enhancements over time um but in a lot
of cases there's not great longitudinal
evidence to support the ongoing usage of
things that do have a positive acute
impact uh and in this case you know i i
won't say that there's you know 100 slam
dunk evidence that an external
attentional focus
both improves acute performance and
those improvements in acute performance
necessarily lead to larger enhancements
in performance long term
but the evidence does at least lean in
that direction
so there's there's strong evidence that
an external attentional focus will
acutely enhance performance and i would
say weak to moderate evidence that that
will also lead to larger performance
enhancements over time
now are you aware of much research other
than that one schoenfeld paper about
hypertrophy as an outcome
uh with internal external focus
um yeah i mean i've had a lot of clients
in the past who um
they'll mention you know man i'm really
struggling feeling the mind muscle
connection with this particular exercise
and
usually
my
response to that is like that's that's
fine like let's just adopt an external
focus when we're doing that exercise
and
maybe at some point we'll kind of
develop that mind muscle connection if
you know for i think there are a lot of
people who
perceive that to be very important um
i'm not necessarily
fully convinced that the mind muscle
connection is necessarily that important
in terms of training adaptations but at
the very least if you're working with a
client who is clearly
uh frustrated with their lack of ability
to find the mind muscle connection if
nothing else i mean results of the meta
aside
using this idea of an external focus can
be a really nice way to alleviate that
concern and say well if the if the
internal focus is not working for us we
have an alternative yeah and and if
anything i lean toward kind of favoring
the external focus anyway but but at the
very least it's a great way for clients
to kind of uh
alleviate that concern and buy back into
being excited about that movement yeah
no i i agree with that perspective and i
just want to make one thing clear um
i think there is perhaps a
slight chance that some people
will perceive what i said in that
segment to potentially be taking shots
at at brad and that study like
you know ooh was he implying that the
biceps findings in this study can
conflict with other research is he
saying that that study was bad no i was
definitely not trying to imply that
brad's a good researcher and as far as i
can tell that study was was done well
um i i j i just wanted to note
uh specifically on on the hypertrophy
side of things
that i do think i do think some people
are
maybe being a little bit hasty um
in terms of trying to
uh
trying to make what what they perceive
to be
a very strong case that an internal
attentional focus
is definitely better for hypertrophy
than an external attentional focus uh so
there is there is acute evidence so th
this this study uh the meta that i
reviewed wasn't interested in this
particular question but there is other
research looking at the impact of
internal versus external attentional
focus on other acute measures so one of
those being uh emg measures and so an
internal attentional focus not always
but often results in higher emg of the
muscle being assessed than an external
attentional focus does and so you might
look at that and say oh well this this
might be indicative of greater muscle
activation therefore maybe we should
predict that an internal attentional
focus will lead to more muscle growth
and then there is that one longitudinal
schoenfeld paper
where an internal attentional focus did
result in more biceps growth than an
external focus and so people kind of
look at that and they're like ooh we
have some acute evidence and a little
bit of longitudinal evidence that seems
to back it up
therefore
we can say very confidently that an
internal attentional focus is definitely
going to result in more growth than an
external attentional focus and i think
that people
like i don't even know that that's wrong
but i think that people may have the
card ahead of the horse a little bit
where
the the acute emg stuff isn't like super
solid so some studies do find that in
that an internal focus results in in
higher muscle emg
a lot of studies don't though um and the
ones that do find a difference tend to
find a relatively small difference and
you know then that opens a whole can of
worms it's like oh well we're seeing a
seven percent difference in uh
pec emg expressed as a percentage of emg
observed in a maximum voluntary
isometric contraction a seven percent
mvic difference in pec emg
what does what does that equate to in
terms of uh millimeters of pec thickness
accrued over 16 weeks i don't have an
answer and that's because no one has an
answer because uh emg hasn't been
validated as a longitudinal proxy for
hypertrophy uh and even if it had been
there you know were
a long way away from having a dose
response relationship to say like ooh
this this magnitude of emg difference is
likely to result in this magnitude of
hypertrophy difference and then as far
as the longitudinal stuff goes
like you brought up as far as i'm aware
it is just that one study they assessed
two muscles and they found that an
internal attentional focus maybe
resulted in more growth in one muscle
not the other muscle so it's you know
it even in the longitudinal evidence
that exists it's kind of a coin flip um
so yeah i mean it very well could be a
decade down the road we do have really
strong evidence that an internal
attentional focus enhances hypertrophy
external attentional focus enhances
strength and we have a really really
strong
evidentiary basis for those claims as it
is now i think we have a
weak to moderate evidentiary basis for
saying an external attentional focus
will will probably enhance strength
gains over time i think we have a very
weak evidentiary basis for saying that
an internal attentional focus enhances
hypertrophy over time i do think that
the weight of the evidence tilts in that
direction but i think that it's a
somewhat tenuous tilt as it is now and
that uh
maybe people are putting too many eggs
in those baskets uh yeah and for now you
know uh you're probably gonna grow with
either attentional focus so if someone
does just prefer to do hypertrophy
training with a focus on performance in
the gym and lifting with an external
attentional focus
that definitely should still result in
muscle growth and you know even if it is
like slightly sub-optimal uh compared to
an internal attentional focus if that's
just how someone prefers training like
it is still productive training and i i
wouldn't want to
dissuade someone from doing that yeah
and it is a little bit easier to
objectively track progress over time
when when there's a little bit more of
the focus on the performance related
outcome yeah you know rather than just
like hmm are my exercises feeling as
good as they were six weeks ago in this
training block yeah yeah but yeah just
to reinforce your point like pointing
out that a small study disagrees with
other studies in the area if you look at
any meta-analysis not any but in a
perfect world if you looked at any
meta-analysis you would see a funnel
plot you know where
uh
as you look at some of these small
studies we do expect um
like baked into what we're doing with a
meta-analysis we expect
that some of the smaller studies are
going to
you know fairly substantially
overestimate the effect size and others
are going to fairly substantially
underestimate the effect size so to see
one of these kind of small randomized
controlled trials in this area
disagreeing with others on a similar
topic that is not a unique thing and it
certainly doesn't imply that it was a
bad or poorly done study oh for sure
yeah yeah now greg you've got two left
correct i think i've only got one left
because i was going to say you've done
the interference effect exactly you
covered that study on the podcast yeah
so uh yeah the the the next uh study
that i looked at in the best of issue uh
is compatibility of concurrent aerobic
and strength training for skeletal
muscle size and function an updated
systematic review and meta-analysis by
schuman and colleagues and like eric
said i'm positive that we've talked
about this on the podcast before so uh i
figure we can probably just link that in
the show notes and uh move on to my last
one
which is a study looking at uh
sarcoplasmic hypertrophy so the title of
this one was an update on sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy that was my title for the
article the study i was looking at was
myofibril and mitochondrial area changes
and type 1 and type 2 fibers following
10 weeks of resistance training in
previously untrained men
by rupal and colleagues
and so in this study they recruited a
sample of 15 untrained men and they
completed 10 weeks of resistance
training following a moderate rep full
body resistance training program so they
were mostly doing sets of six to ten
reps pretty close to failure
and so this study looked at a ton of
outcomes uh like it came out of a lab
that does a lot of um
what is the word i'm looking at like it
looks at a lot of like molecular
outcomes um but for the purposes of this
study i was mostly interested in three
outcomes which was
changes in fiber cross-sectional area
changes in myofibril fibrillar density
so the proportion of each muscle fiber
that was composed of myofibrils which is
where contractile proteins are housed
and also changes in mitochondrial
density so what percentage of each fiber
is taken up by mitochondria which as we
all know are the powerhouse of the cell
and so uh
i so i wanted to talk about this through
the lens of sarcoplasmic hypertrophy and
before going further i think it's worth
just kind of giving my operational
definition of what sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy is so sarcoplasm is
basically every part of a muscle fiber
that
is not the myofibril is not the the
contractile like the the parts of the
fiber where the the um
contractile proteins are housed so you
have your
uh just your your sarcoplasm kind of
proper the
uh the the aqueous solution that
everything kind of floats in you have
your other organelles uh you have your
your mitochondria um
you know and pretty much everything that
isn't just contractile protein
and so when muscle fibers grow
uh you
tend to and hopefully do accrue more
contractile protein but you also crew
more of the other stuff as well so you
so you also have an increase in
sarcoplasm and so my operational
definition of sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
is a disproportionate
increase in the sarcoplasm portion of
the fiber relative to the contractile
portion of the fiber so if a muscle
fiber was previously
70 myofibrils and 30 sarcoplasm and it
increases in size by 20 percent
but at the end it's still 70 myofibrils
30 sarcoplasm
the total amount of sarcoplasm in the
fiber increase because the fiber got
bigger but proportionally the increases
in
sarcoplasm and myofibrils were the same
so that would be
no sarcoplasmic hypertrophy occurring
but if the total amount of myofibrils
stayed the same and the total increase
in muscle fiber size was solely
accounted for by just expansion of the
sarcoplasm such that at the end now it's
60 myofibrils and 40 sarcoplasm that
would be an example of sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy occurring so fiber growth
occurs but the there's a
disproportionate increase in the
sarcoplasm portion of the fiber and a
net decrease in the relative proportion
of myofibril
area taken up in the fiber
and then on the flip side myofibrillar
packing can occur so
if a fiber grows and at the end now it's
80 myofibrils and only 20 sarcoplasm
that's the opposite of sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy that's myofibrillar packing
so now
you you had a disproportionate increase
in contractile proteins relative to
everything else as the fiber grew so
those are those are my my operational
definitions of those terms
and so uh yeah going back to the results
of this study
they trained for a while muscles grew as
you would hope they would
uh and on average there weren't net
changes in myofibrillar density within
the entire uh sample so there were just
kind of nominal decreases in
myofibrillar density of like three to
five percent um on average but that
wasn't statistically significant and so
it seems like within this this group of
subjects after 10 weeks of resistance
training
you didn't see significant sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy or myofibrillar packing the
ratio of myofibrils to sarcoplasm within
the sample on average was was maintained
over those 10 weeks as hypertrophy
occurred
but
this study
did what i always like to see which is
plotting individual data points to get
an idea of the total range of outcomes
observed within the sample so
even though there was not
an average change in myofibrillar
density
within the entire cohort when you look
at the individual data points you see
everything from
a 20 decrease in myofibrillar area
within the fibers which would be
suggestive of considerable sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy occurring to about a 20
percent uh increase in myofibrillar area
of the fibers which would suggest very
considerable myofibrillar packing
occurring so a decrease in in uh the
total portion of sarcoplasm so that's
that's a very wide range of individual
responses
uh and i think that's noteworthy
because and you know at this point i
could i might just be a boomer and i'm
responding to
an argument that not all that many
people are making anymore but i remember
it wasn't that long ago
where
it was considered that the entire idea
of sarcoplasmic hypertrophy was
necessarily bro science because
um you know there was the assumption
that the ratio of myofibrils to
sarcoplasm within muscle fibers
had to be constrained within pretty
tight limits and that if it wasn't there
would be like catastrophic uh energetic
consequences to that and so so basically
just on principle sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy couldn't occur because the
ratio of myofibrils to sarcoplasm
couldn't change that much and
i do think that this study provides
pretty strong evidence against that
perspective like if if we're seeing
shifts in myofibril or density of 20 one
way or the other
that necessarily implies that there's
not a super tight range
that the ratio of myofibrils to
sarcoplasm has to fall within so i think
that at minimum this opens the door for
sarcoplasmic hypertrophy being a
possibility if that uh argument i
previously expressed was something you
were you were previously holding on to
and i'll note that there is there is
human evidence for sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy in the first place so uh
yeah i i don't find that argument
particularly compelling but um yeah i i
did think that the total range
demonstrated in this article was very
interesting and i'll also note that
you know some of it might just be
some degree of measurement error so you
know something that looks like a 20
increase might be an actual 15 percent
increase but you know with any
measurement technique there's some
amount of of potential for error
involved but i i don't think that you
can explain plus or minus 20
just solely as measurement error um so
that was something i found interesting
the other thing i found very interesting
in this study
is there was a
uh there was no relationship so there
were two more things i found interesting
one of them was that there was no
relationship between
the change in myofibrillar area and the
total amount of hypertrophy that
occurred so essentially what this study
found is that uh you know if if you
experience more
uh total hypertrophy that's not
reflective of greater sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy occurring or myofibrillar
packing occurring so you know if someone
grows a lot you can't you can't
necessarily assume like oh well they
just experienced a ton of sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy it's not like real growth or
whatever like the
the amount of sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
that occurred on an individual basis was
not predictive of the total amount of
hypertrophy that occurred which i
thought was neat and then the thing that
i found the neatest in this study
um because it plays into a little pet
theory that i that i haven't fully
fleshed out and i don't think is fully
uh validated yet but it's it's something
that i believe it's within my scientific
head canon um so they found that there
was a negative relationship
between
changes in fiber cross-sectional area
and changes in mitochondrial density so
what that means is that if you didn't
experience an increase in mitochondrial
density that was predictive of you
experiencing more hypertrophy versus if
you did
have a
large
enhancement in mitochondrial density
that was predictive of not much
hypertrophy occurring and so
the thing i liked about this and and
what i mentioned about my head canon is
i think that one of the primary limiters
of hypertrophy is primarily energetic so
uh basically if
if a fiber is having a really easy time
maintaining
energy homeostasis
it will be more willing to grow so
basically a fiber growing
is an energetic stress because now
there's more total stuff inside the
fiber and so when you exercise it's
burning more total energy that it then
has to
you know re-synthesize atp for so that
the fiber itself isn't
in an energetically threatened state um
and so i i think that that is one of the
constraints on hypertrophy and so what
i'm reading into this association which
might not be justified at all like i
said this is just my interpretation uh
is that you know maybe this suggests
that the people who didn't have an
enhancement in mitochondrial density
they already had muscle fibers that were
metabolically equipped to be able to
grow like it was permissive of growth
because uh they were just in a more
chill energetic state overall
versus people who you know maybe they do
some resistance training and their their
fibers aren't like oh [ __ ] i need to get
bigger and grow they're like oh [ __ ] i
did some bicep curls and now
like
the muscle fibers in my biceps
we're barely able to to turn over atp
fast enough to avoid an energetic
cataclysm we don't need to worry about
growing we need to worry about making
more mitochondria to to generate enough
energy for further resistance training
um like so that that's what i kind of
read into this association uh but you
know that could be totally spurious and
it could just be that i'm
kind of too too fixated on my idea of of
energetic homeostasis being a a
regulator of hypertrophy uh but i i
found that association interesting but
yeah biggest takeaway from the study
when when a group of people does the
same resistance training program
uh
some of them might experience a ton of
myofibrillar
packing some of them might experience
quite a bit of sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
uh and you know that's
just in people training with the same
rep ranges like there there's this idea
that uh sarcoplasmic hypertrophy will
only occur and necessarily occurs if you
do a lot of low load training and that
heavier training which is how i how i
would characterize the training in this
study so sets of six to ten reps that's
that's kind of on the low to moderate uh
end
so people think that that's necessarily
going to result in
either no change in in myofibrillar
density or maybe even an increase in
myofibrillar density but you know that's
not the type of training that would
result in sarcoplasmic hypertrophy
that's only low load training that does
that um yeah this study found that at
least within this sample uh people doing
the same training program some of them
experienced a lot of sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy some of them experienced a
lot of myofibrillar packing and those
two things weren't predictive of the
overall hypertrophy people experienced
so ultimately i think that this is a
very
interesting area of research but they're
also just an enormous amount of open
questions like i don't think we fully
characterized the total extent to which
sarcoplasmic hypertrophy can occur um
we definitely haven't established that a
particular type of training
increases your odds for sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy versus myofibrillar packing
to occur like people think that that's
very established it is not um
we don't know what's what's predictive
of uh
of you know those various outcomes
occurring it's it's just something where
there's a wide open world in front of us
where
it does seem to be a phenomenon that can
happen but we don't exactly know what
causes it or predicts it uh so i'm you
know i i'm hoping that we'll see a lot
more uh interesting research on
sarcoplasmic hypertrophy in the future
i hope so
uh so
we in the mat the best of mass issue
we've got all the stuff we've discussed
up to this point as we alluded to we
also have another article from you about
the interference effect which we've
discussed on the podcast previously but
i do in our last couple moments here
want to give a rundown of other things
in this best of mass issue and it's it's
over 130 pages plus two videos so
there's a lot of information in here uh
i have some additional articles one is
called replacing animal proteins with
plant proteins are there any downsides
and i talk a little bit about some of
the potential micronutrient shortcomings
that you might find if you switch over
from an omnivorous diet to a fully
plant-based diet and what to do about
that uh on that topic i should note that
dan feldman
reached out to me and mentioned that i
am not going to the doctor for vitamin
testing just because i'm an old man
who's stubborn he brought to my
attention apparently in the united
states a lot of health care plans do
cover
uh like an annual like general health
visit and i think that's a requirement
for many programs the united states like
the way he framed it it sounds like
you probably do have that in your your
policy especially if you got it over the
uh
uh the marketplace um
way to get insurance uh and most
company-sponsored programs include that
as well i don't know how they would do
with follow-up testing if you for
example did that annual screening and
they said yeah you're short on this
multi uh this uh micronutrient i'm not
sure how the follow-up visits would
would be covered under various programs
i don't know uh but
props to dan uh to dan feldman for
bringing that to my attention
although
his credibility is pretty tarnished
because he did ask a question about thc
on the podcast so
that's true not a good not a good guy
not a reputable guy but nonetheless
dan uh dan feldman thank you for
bringing that to my attention and of
course i'm kidding dan is awesome uh
what what did we decide his instagram
handle was i think it's at powerlifting
dietitian yeah so he's a very
experienced power lifter excellent
dietitian be sure to check him out uh
anyway moving on the uh the next article
i had was collagen protein isn't great
for promoting muscle hypertrophy i talk
about a randomized controlled trial
directly comparing a leucine matched
dose of whey protein versus collagen
protein so obviously collagen protein
doesn't have leucine or doesn't have a
meaningful amount of it so what what
they did in the study was they matched
for leucine to try to
to try to give the collagen a chance to
do something but
collagen is a a very
unfavorable protein based on its amino
acid breakdown it's not going to do a
great job supporting
muscle hypertrophy in the article i talk
about uh what collagen protein might
maybe be good for
i also
present my perspective that i think
glycine supplementation makes more sense
than collagen supplementation
in most instances where people are
supplementing with collagen but then i
also talk about what to do if you do
have a significant amount of collagen in
your daily routine in your daily diet
how do you account for that in the
context of your
daily protein target so all about
collagen what it does what it doesn't do
and how to incorporate it into a diet
without displacing proteins that
actually will help you build skeletal
muscle
i've got an article called adding
another layer to the energy compensation
discussion uh i think i've alluded to
this particular article on the podcast
but basically it was a fascinating
article that found when you are in
neutral or positive energy balance the
additive model
of energy expenditure does a great job
and the additive model what we're
talking about here is compensating for
calories burned during exercise so the
additive model basically assumes that
there's no compensation if you add 100
calories of cardio to your daily routine
the additive model assumes your total
daily energy expenditure will go up by
100 calories no compensation
the uh
the
um
alternative model
would suggest
that you know if you added
uh
100 calories of cardio to your daily
routine you would compensate for maybe
20 30 40 of those calories so um you
know the the additive model like i said
would assume ev
all 100 of those calories are gonna get
added to your total daily energy
expenditure um but in contrast the
alternative model would suggest that uh
basically you added 100 calories of
cardio to your daily routine but total
daily energy expenditure might only go
up by 60 70 80 calories something like
that so uh what this study did was it
compared these two different models of
energy expenditure it found the additive
model actually did fine if you're in
neutral or positive energy balance
whereas uh the alternative model that
does incorporate compensation does a
much better job fitting the data when
you are looking at negative energy
balance uh so it's really fascinating it
kind of gets into that conversation of
the constrained energy expenditure model
um how it compares to the additive model
and which one makes sense in which
particular circumstance so the idea of
compensating for exercise calories uh
there appears to be some significant
variation from person to person but
there also appears to be variation based
on whether or not you're a negative
energy balance which has really
important ramifications for dieting and
also important ramifications for how we
fuel
uh athletes with really high activity
levels in two very different
circumstances uh where where we have to
decide how much additional energy intake
is needed to uh to account for some of
this uh physical activity that's going
on
uh the next one i have is it's called is
everything that's measured worth
managing and in this article i basically
talk about what wearable technologies
are good for and more importantly what
they're not good for so it was a new
study comparing some of the newer
wearable technologies on the market and
the short version is they do a pretty
good job generally of tracking heart
rate and step count but for energy
expenditure during a variety of
different activities
they do a very poor job
too for a job to reliably lean on when
you're making changes to your caloric
target or your caloric intake from day
to day
so i do a
pretty deep look at
how those different technologies stack
up and where they have shortcomings and
then finally i had an article called
cold exposure for fat loss physiology
can be cool without being useful and
that is a pun that's what we call a pun
in the writing business
but
people have been popularizing cold
exposure lately i think it's something
that just kind of goes in waves it gets
really uh hyped up for a minute and then
it goes away for a while it's way on the
upswing right now a lot of people are
hyping it up and one of the things i
find really interesting about these very
mechanistically driven fairly
speculative concepts
is that they've they often break down
when you just push the people who are
hyping them up and just say yeah yeah
yeah that's very cool physiology is fun
but like
use numbers yeah and when you start
actually using numbers and be like no
but find numbers from human studies and
and then use those to make your argument
a lot of times they fall apart and so
all i really do in this article of
course i review a study about some some
cold water swimmers
and how they respond to cold exposure in
terms of energy expenditure how their
body composition differs to uh matched
controls but more importantly i just say
like okay let's say this is an idea
let's actually use the evidence which
exists
and put numbers to it and figure out how
helpful is
a cold exposure program for fat loss and
simply based on the arithmetic when we
look at how much energy expenditure goes
up in response to acute cold exposure
and how long you could feasibly actually
expose yourself to that level of cold
as far as i can tell from my perspective
it looks like a dead end uh the the
increase in energy expenditure is too
short-lived and too small in magnitude
and the intervention itself is too
unbearably uncomfortable to say like yes
this is your path to clinically relevant
or practically relevant fat loss you
know it it reminds me a lot of uh like
fat burner supplements which are for the
most part just caffeine right like oh
yeah this
this boosts your metabolism so you'll
burn more energy and lose weight and
it's like
yeah but like but like how much though
and it's like oh well uh you know over
over the time that it's in your system
maybe like 30 calories it's like okay so
it's a none right but it's like okay so
you know i i have a choice between
having a trivial impact on my total
energy expenditure from
consuming a lot of caffeine getting
wired very pleasant i love it would
highly recommend it versus like freezing
my ass off for 30 minutes and it's like
both neither of them neither of them is
really going to do anything but like
at least one of them's kind of fun
yeah
absolutely yeah i mean so
that was my big takeaway is like
whenever someone's given me some flashy
mechanistic speculative idea like oh
this is gonna change the game in terms
of fat loss i'm like use numbers and and
then if if they're not willing to put
numbers on it
it's probably more hype than it is
actual substance yeah so um those were
the remainder of the studies uh or the
articles that i have in the best of mass
issue i do want to briefly mention uh
zordos and helms obviously make
fantastic uh contributions every month
to mass they should be discussing these
on the iron culture podcast on may 2nd
um but for example
we've got an article by mike when and
how are flexible templates actually
useful so talking about how to use
flexible training templates uh article
by helms the link between overtraining
and low energy availability really
fascinating article talking about how it
can be actually in the literature quite
difficult to distinguish between uh you
know overreaching and over training
versus low energy availability there's a
lot of overlapping overlapping symptoms
there that can and they often appear in
unison or or there are instances where
you think it might be one or the other
and it's hard to tell which
so really insightful article there
article by mike zordos the most
comprehensive look at proximity to
failure yet talking about how close to
failure you should train
and then we've got some videos
dr zordos has a video about time
efficient programming strategies for
resistance training and then dr helms
has a video
about periodizing singles in
powerlifting training that's something
we've talked about previously
on the podcast
is the idea of
incorporating some heavy singles
and kind of like the laziest way to make
a hypertrophy program into a
powerlifting program is like hey
throw some singles at the beginning
right so uh dr helms talks all about how
to uh kind of strategically incorporate
some of those singles into your
powerlifting training so
that uh sums up everything that's in the
best of mass issue and like i said
it is entirely free to download and we
will put the link in the show notes
so that does it for this episode now to
play us out we've got actually a couple
things sometimes we're we're really
reaching for topics here but uh we've
got some topical stuff here so in the
past i've taken a pretty firm stance
against reading um and i've gotten some
pushback for that but i feel like i've
been totally vindicated
we have talked in the past about how the
my one exception where i will allow
reading is textbooks i think textbooks
are really valuable and i do read them
regularly so um i actually just went on
like some of the
second-hand book websites where you can
order like a 200 textbook for like seven
dollars because it's one edition old but
has literally all the same information
that that is my hack like if you're
buying the current version of a textbook
no go one edition older and get it for
like
literally pennies on the dollar yeah but
um anyway i i did a big um definitely
don't go to libgen that's
illegal and no one on this podcast would
ever use a website like that
i i like to have a physical textbook
like that that is the
oldest thing about my personality is i
want to turn the page i want to feel the
book
uh but anyway i i bought like
eight nine ten textbooks something like
that and i was like okay
this is my one opportunity to get away
from
all the wacky stuff you see on the
internet about nutrition and all that
crap like i'm going and buying
specifically
academic textbooks and the way i found
them was like i i was going on like uh
research you know uh websites where
uh researchers and university professors
talk about like hey i'm teaching psych
301 what textbook should i use for
health behavior psychology right so like
these are legit textbooks so i ordered
them and the the site that i ordered
them from was like oh you like science
and you like nutrition i've got some
recommendations for you and so this
automated email comes into my box
uh three recommendations
that i got
since i like the really hard-hitting
science and i like nutrition and this
was three out of like seven right yeah
it was like nearly half of the
recommendations yeah yeah
three that came up gary taubes
who
uh is really big on an approach to
nutrition that many are saying is fully
debunked at this point and they're
saying it more and more and they are
saying
we talked about the most recent uh
it was it wasn't even a review paper
like a viewpoint paper that he was on uh
comparing the
energy balance model versus the
carbohydrate insulin model
and
we talked about that paper and and
showed in detail how
the previous version of the carbohydrate
insulin model that he put forth has been
so thoroughly debunked that the current
iteration of the carbohydrate insulin
model that they're on
is now fully consistent with the energy
balance model right so
whatever book they're recommending is
some prior version of
uh of that hypothesis that has now been
so thoroughly debunked that he himself
is now on papers proposing a new version
of the model that
he i don't think he would ever
admit this out loud but at least tacitly
admits that the old version uh
that his books are based on
is is
just not tenable anymore correct uh
speaking of debunked
another recommendation was brian wansink
um
and
i'm not gonna make any uh libelous or
slanderous claims on the show but just
google brian wansink see what comes up
um
basically uh
he used to be a professor if he had his
way he would still be a professor but
he no longer is because some of his
research and emails came out and they
were not favorable the research was a
bit unreliable and led to many many
retractions and a loss of employment
that that's a diplomatic way to approach
that right sure yeah
it led to a crisis in psychology
basically correct it was part of a part
of a kind of movement to say hey we need
to make sure our data
are reliable yeah uh and then there was
finally uh david avocado wolf hell yeah
who um i don't know you would know his
greatest hits better than i would dude i
love david avocado wolf so
um
he's he's not even loki fell off like he
high key fell off like his his facebook
page go back to like 2015 2016 was a
gold mine it was incredible and i don't
mean a gold mine of
good information i mean a gold mine of
funny information like he would be
posting stuff four times a day that was
just the most insane [ __ ] he'd be like
you know what like your heart chakra has
the same octave of vibration as mandarin
oranges and so if you eat mandarin
oranges it's good for your soul just
like stuff that for the most part was
generally harmless but also just just
insane just concentrated distilled
chaotic just psychotic type [ __ ] on par
with some of our we've had some in in
the facebook group some posts about like
how to choose your intermittent fasting
schedule based on your foot shape yeah
yeah like it was it was that type of
stuff just like you know like
uh the the confluence of
nutrition conspiracy theories with with
uh like a
a fringe version of new age spirituality
like
further out than even like most new age
spirituality it was
incredible content bad content but
incredible very fun to consume uh he's
he's like i said very much fallen off in
recent years like so uh when we talked
about this when this when this email
came in and you showed me that there was
a david avocado wolf uh book
recommendation um in this email i was
just like dude i haven't heard anything
from him in like three years he's not
popping up on my timeline anymore i
don't see people even like sharing his
stuff to debunk it so i was like what is
he up to these days i go to his facebook
page and now it's just like
it's it's like it's just boring [ __ ] so
he'll just like share an article from
some like disreputable news outlet and
just be like thoughts and like that's it
that's that's all of his content he's
just sharing stuff
two dozen times a day but it's it's like
not even fun conspiracy [ __ ] it's like
boring kind of like normie conspiracy
[ __ ] and it's just like what are your
thoughts about this and it's
it's a boring media strategy i i know
this guy has more juice than this he has
more sauce than what he's showing on
facebook these days and i think
i think when you listen to this you need
to go to david avocado wolf's facebook
page and just everything he posts just
comment be like bring back the old david
david avocado wolf like we we need him
to get back into like 2015 form because
he was
one of the funniest accounts on facebook
and he's just not anymore yeah yeah that
is definitely true um but anyway yeah so
like to me at first i thought it was
hilarious that i got this email and then
i'll admit it was a little bit
disheartening because it's like
if there was one place i thought you
could get away from this absolute
nonsense i would have thought it's like
i'm gonna go purchase
intro to health behavior psychology
third edition by professor so and so and
they're like nah dude read david avocado
wolf and i'm like [ __ ] that's awesome uh
all right what do you got
yeah so i have two media recommendations
and one media anti recommendation uh so
there are
two recent shows one is called severance
and the other is called slow horses both
of them on apple tv if you're not a
subscriber i'm sure they have a free
trial just watch them both and cancel um
but yeah so severance is a very uh
engrossing psychological thriller the
basic premise is that there is this
company where if you work for them they
implant a chip in your head such that it
completely splits your personality where
when you go home you don't remember
anything that happened during the work
day and during the work day you can't
remember anything that happened
when you were at home so it basically
splits you into two separate people that
have no
memory or recollection of what's going
on with the other one um so it's a cool
premise and they execute on execute on
it really well a very good show would
highly recommend and there's another
show that we're currently watching
called slow horses it's a
it's like a british
crime
espionage thriller type show i would say
uh starring well i guess co-starring
gary oldman who
he's completely unrecognizable like the
the
hair and makeup department did really
did a number on him uh but it it is very
convincing um
he delivers a tremendous performance and
it's uh the the finale i think is coming
up this week so uh
lindsay and i are still waiting to see
if they'll stick the landing but thus
far it's it's been a very very good show
we we have a huge soft spot for
like
prestige british crime shows i don't
know why but like the the first couple
seasons of luther very very good um
broadchurch incredible television uh and
thus far slow horses is no exception
it's it's a very good show and my media
anti-recommendation i don't know why i
did this to myself
but
went on netflix and it was recommending
a new show called is it cake
and the entire premise is
bakers who bake very who bake cakes that
look like very realistic versions of
things that aren't cakes compete to see
who can make the most realistic looking
uh
cakes that look like
burgers or shoes or whatever and
my god it is
it is the second most painful 30 minutes
of television i've ever consumed the the
most painful is this other netflix show
called i can see your voice which holy
[ __ ] that shows so bad but is it cake is
the second worst episode of television
i've ever seen so if you want to
if you just want to have a bad [ __ ]
time and consume trash content check out
is it cake and if you value your time
and sanity do not check out is it cake
perfect
all right uh so hopefully that'll help
people make their uh television
decisions coming up here uh this is our
first two hour episode in a while god
damn it no
no negative comments will be accepted no
hate mail will be accepted we are
framing this as a two-part podcast so
this is actually two episodes but we're
going to release them simultaneously as
one file with no dividing mark yeah okay
so uh three
this is our version of uh speaker box
and the love below
sure yeah yeah um so we're gonna have
like three or four people who are happy
who are like yeah bring back the two
hour episodes and then a lot of people
are like hey my work commute is not this
long so anyway we will get back to our
normal form and get closer to an hour
moving forward but anyway uh we really
appreciate you joining us in this
special uh double episode
like i mentioned uh check the show notes
to get the um
the best of mass issue and if you're
interested enough go ahead and consider
subscribing during our sale which ends
tuesday may 3rd as always thank you for
listening and we'll see you next week
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you